michel thomas merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur rt france alors depuis
plusieurs mois on le voyait à la
situation économique au liban ne cesse
de se dégrader la dévaluation de la
livre libanaise peut-elle plongé le pays
finalement dans un chaos total désormais
au oui il ya de fortes craintes à ce
sujet parce que à la crise socio
économique qui a éclaté au grand jour le
17 octobre c'était un facteur
fondamental est venu s'ajouter
actuellement le problème de la doua ce
qu'on appelle la noix césar c'est à dire
des sanctions américains qui doivent
être appliquées à la syrie et au
hezbollah alors beaucoup de plusieurs
milieux milieux politiques accusent
actuellement 2es bonheur de pomper des
dollars du marché libanais pour
renflouer un peu un tant soit peu la
ligue simienne oki a aussi enregistré
ces derniers jours une chute drastique
au niveau du taux de change par rapport
au dollar la livre syrienne est passée
d'un taux de retour 1 dollar 50 livres
pour un dollar
ces derniers jours ce taux a atteint
3000 livres syrien pour un dollar alors
du coup certains milieux politiques
accusent à ce moment là de faire une
contrebande de deux billets verts de
devises fortes pour renflouer un peu la
diction et pour dans le cadre de sa
stratégie visant à sauver le régime de
bachar el-assad alors du coup le
résultat au liban et que yellow dollars
sur le marché noir a dépassé le taux de
6000 livres alors qu'il était de au
départ avant la crise la crise à 1500
puis graduellement il est monté à 2000
2500 et ces derniers jours chez les
changeurs il était à 3000
alors tant qu en 24 ou 48 heures il a
doublé les passé de 3000 à 5000 ou 6000
livres alors michel thomas dans ce
contexte quelle est la marge de
manoeuvre du
gouvernement quelles sont ces leviers et
finalement pour faire repartir
l'économie
je ne sais pas s'ils ont une marge de
manoeuvre parce que ce qui se passe
aussi c'est que aussi des milieux
politiques souverainistes en appelle ici
les milieux souverainistes accuse le
hezbollah de faire pression sur le
gouvernement pour court circuiter
totalement la loire césar donc
actuellement sur le plan économique ce
que peut faire le gouvernement s'est
essayé de mettre un terme au marché noir
au niveau du marché des changes et
surtout de surveiller les frontières
avec la syrie parce qu'il ya un trafic
de contrebande qui se fait en direction
de la syrie dans contrebande et de fioul
carburant et de famille parce qu'il ya
une forte pénurie de carburant de
famille n'en suis donc ce que peut faire
c'est essayer de contrôler le marché des
changes
je ne sais pas si on en a les moyens il
a convoqué aujourd'hui il a tenu une
réunion avec l'échangeur avec le
syndicat des changeurs une deuxième
réunion a eu lieu avec l'association des
banques pour essayer d'injecter de
dollars sur le marché libanais il a
demandé à la banque du liban d'injecter
des dollars sur le marché libanais pour
calmer un peu le juré pour faire baisser
le taux de change du dollar par rapport
à la livre libanaise allait là aussi
beaucoup de milieux craignent que ces
données relatives à la série
alors on entendait par ailleurs la
colère des manifestants contre le
gouvernement contre les autorités ces
manifestations à ce qu'elle pourrait se
transformer en insurrection contre le
pouvoir en place
est-ce qu'en tout cas c'est une crainte
de du côté des autorités
oui effectivement il ya une forte
crainte que parce que lorsque la
dégradation socio économiques dépassent
la ligne rouge et que le dollar était à
cs 6000 7000 livres et les entreprises
sont en train de fermer l'une après
l'autre au taux de chômage a dépassé les
50%
donc il ya un
un grand risque que cet accès de colère
se transforme vraiment en insurrection
dirigée contre le gouvernement
allah ya un facteur politique ici qu'ils
entrent en jeu aussi
certaines rumeurs font état de la
volonté encore une fois de l'escola de
faire tomber ce suscité ce gouvernement
nous sommes dit il les juge incapable de
faire face à la crise mais en tous cas
quelle que soit des manoeuvres
politiques sur le plan populaire il y a
un sentiment autour de d'insurrection un
sentiment de fraude qui peut aller très
loin et on a vu hier soir toutes les
régions du pays
dans la capitale dans les banlieues et
même dans les régions périphériques sont
descendus en soirée et j'ai vu vraiment
un climat insurrectionnel un peu partout
donc ça peut déraper effectivement il ya
de fortes chances que ça puisse déraper
si rien est fait ici le gouvernement
n'arrive pas à juguler un peu la
situation et empêcher une une forte
dépréciation supplémentaire de la livre
donc c'est un dossier complexe
il y a il ya des facteurs autres que le
liban subit depuis depuis des dizaines
d'années en raison d'une mal gouvernance
ou plutôt ce n'est même plus mal
gouvernance et une gouvernance et en
raison d'une corruption galopante et de
l'affairisme d'une grande partie de la
classe politique et rssi et du
clientélisme qui a abouti à un déficit
public que le liban n'arrive pas à la
maison des merci michel tout va on va
bien entendu continuer à suivre de très
près la situation au liban merci michel
dumas d'avoir répondu à nos questions je
rappelle que vous êtes rédacteur en chef
de lorient le